même une réforme mais la loi jospin
marque cependant des changements
significatifs pour le système éducatif
les enseignants futurs instituteurs et
professeurs seront désormais tous
recrutés au même niveau
la licence est formé ensuite dans des
nouveaux instituts universitaires de
formation des maîtres
ouverture de ces instituts dans un an
plus deux trimestres
on travaillera cette semaine pour deux
semaines de repos l'année scolaire
devrait se terminer environ mi juillet
pour reprendre environ mi septembre la
scolarité des élèves est désormais
divisé en cycle si peu de trois ans en
primaire et de deux ans en secondaire
pas de redoublement à l'intérieur d'un
cycle pour les diplômes de
l'enseignement technique et
professionnel
les jeunes feront des stages
obligatoires dans les entreprises
françaises ou étrangères
les parents d'élèves délégués aux
conseils départementaux académique et
nationaux pourront bénéficier d'une
autorisation d'absence des entreprises
et seront indemnisés
c'est un pas vers un véritable statut de
parents d'élèves
en revanche en cas de litige sur
l'orientation d'un élève c'est le chef
d'établissement qui tranchera et non les
parents comme le proposait la droite
autre amendement malchanceux celui des
centristes qui se sont vu refuser leur
proposition d'aménager un temps libre
pour les activités extrascolaires ou
religieuse